jean-michel mots choisis tu es le seul à
avoir été avec moi depuis la première
émission et est restée avec moi tu étais
là le 1er avril 2010
elle venait de démissionner du figaro à
l'époque et on va raconter ton
recrutement sans dire le nom mais tu vas
raconté comment s'était passé parce que
tu es le seul qui a été pistonné
on va on va pas se mentir ouais c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on va dit toute la
vérité aux téléspectateurs regardent
c'était la première télé c'était le 1er
avril 2010 jean michel maire on peut
bien avec cigare ou encore les faire
valoir
ça va d'un logiciel iphone fonctionne
merci là quelque chose qui est choquant
quand on regarde les images comme ça
c'est que les moniales c'est aussi une
voix c'est que dès que ça commence
maintenant la voie est maintenant on
peut fermer les yeux on voit les images
que c'est absolument incroyable
les animateurs qui ont une voix aussi
pertinente aussi reconnaissable il a il
a la joie et les cheveux voilà la
première de mon jean michel maire ça
nous fait deux beaux gosses il était
moche été horrible fait était déjà très
bon mois joliette a fait le succès des
pmp mon chéri c'est grâce à toi donc ça
fait dix ans qu'on est là qu'on à
l'antenne et que ça marche encore
énormément benjaouid ans mais tu as déjà
une grosse part aurait une stabilité
j'avais un champ de foire eu un champ de
foire aux foins effet une première fois
mais c'est normal
le truc bonjour me comment tu as été
recrutés dit non à la sédition piercing
toi j'ai passé le casting mais c'est
l'histoire complètement folle moi je
crois au destin
il se trouve que juste avant j'étais au
figaro comme tu l'as dit et je participe
et l'émission culte et au confidentiel
qui s'appelait telle est ma télé avec
julie raynaud reste en france cap sur
tps star
minsheng a disparu depuis et il se
trouve que la dernière me sens que je
démissionnais du figaro dont je ne
pouvais plus participer à cette émission
de tact hommes de la presse
et moi comme je représente ait plus
personne c'était ma dernière oui sauf
que dernier invité de telle est ma télé
c'est cyril hanouna sétois celle qui
était le dernier invité que je voyais
voilà et on les solutions se passe
d'éric julie raynaud qu'on embrasse
exactement on s'était un peu connu avant
par des interview au figaro et
l'émission se termine on se démaquille
et tu partes
et avant de partir qui vivent
aujourd'hui à la prochaine et je te
dirai la prochaine mais moi pas ici en
plus tard parce que moi c'est ma
dernière aujourd'hui et mieux pourquoi
qui parce que j'ai démissionné du figaro
donc j'ai plus de raison d'être là donc
je pars il dit mais tu vas faire quoi
bah j'en sais rien et encore je sais pas
encore ce que je vais faire et tu pars
tu fais trois mètres et tu te retournes
et tu dis bah écoute si ça t'as vu ce
site a rien de prévu la semaine
prochaine jean organise un casting
factea seine-saint-denis aux nouvelles
émissions qui va bientôt être lancée sur
france 4 je sais pas encore quand elle
va s'appeler si certains l'on vient et
j'y suis allé et les le casting s'est
plutôt bien passé mais en forme était
tellement il est tout est bon base de
paris moi j'étais là vraiment pas
meilleur qu'un autre mais voilà j'ai
participé à ce que moi tu sais qu'il est
21h hôtelier j'étais tanné j'avoue
j'étais avec mon associé à des associés
des potes on peut dire non et mon
associé jean michel connaissez mon
associé d'époque et mon associé de
l'époque ne connaissais un peu et il m'a
dit faut absolument que tu prennes jean
michel maire il est vraiment très bon je
me rappelle pas le remercieront direct
je dois le remercier
battus par marseille a dit vas-y c'est
mon frère c'est un ami après que je
reproche aux qualifs plusieurs fois je
remercie c'est grâce à lui je vois là et
c'est mon ami c'est voilà c'est mon
frère et il le sait